hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
sorry how are you how's your week going
oh is it almost over isn't that great I
was working my ass off this week I'm
just you know you get so busy it's like
I'm just trying to get to if I can just
get too much turd then you what do you
think you think it's all gonna be
downhill all the craziness is gonna be
end it's gonna add and we past this
project I'm gonna have my free time back
I can get into my field man but it's a
deal you're the one who booked your
[ __ ] schedule so crazy I'm really not
talking to you I'm talking to me right
now I'm the one who booked the [ __ ]
crazy schedule and then I'm acting like
next month I'm not gonna be me still
without doing any work
on what the whatever the [ __ ] it is that
I'm doing whatever I have a other than
doing this podcast I got today off sort
of run around my daughters get a bigger
bed I had to go pick that [ __ ] thing
up I gotta go put that goddamn thing
together it's a labor of love but you
know it still takes up the time during
the day um and do I get any thanks you
know do I get a ticket a parade do you
see me going on the social media saying
that I'm I under served for so and so
you want to hear me complain all you got
to do is turn on this podcast I like
putting [ __ ] together I don't know what
happens to my brain I just slow
everything down I get [ __ ] patient
instead of impatient I I look at all the
instructions I count out all the things
that I'm supposed to have I set him up
in little piles and I get like super
[ __ ] like anal about the whole thing
right because I'm not gonna say OCD the
way people say narcissist and [ __ ]
sociopath I was just talking about that
with somebody just everything is just
like this like there's four or five
psychological conditions that people who
are not cycle
colleges diagnosed everybody's s
narcissus sociopaths OCD a DD and what's
the last one all this is always his
tapas one family whew
yeah the dumbest family member the one
they had to go last in the rotation can
you can you eat up some innings you've
done [ __ ] right what do we got here I
would say what's your five everybody's
diagnosis narcissistic sociopath OCD a
DD and then I'm gonna say epileptics to
underground would you go what's that
[ __ ] thing autistic on the spectrum
somewhere on the spent your somewhere on
the spectrum you know wide berth 180
degrees all out in frontier right 270
all the way over to 90 that's what I
would say most people have diagnosed is
that you know except I've never gotten
any of those diagnoses I got I've gotten
borderline dyslexic and I most have been
diagnosed as a [ __ ] anyway I've been all
over the map this past month and I
haven't had time to work out but two
sets that shouldn't stop you from living
the best you that you can while someone
else sells to Getti their clothes and
sleeps on a concrete slab in a country
that for some reason is considered less
lesser then I've still been able to get
like workouts in I just do the body
white ones which is easy for your legs
right a squats and whatnot planks and
whatnot and all that type of [ __ ] and
you know I've [ __ ] jacked my shoulder
a couple times but I've even just you
know I don't [ __ ] just freeze it up
again I keep it moving you know oh [ __ ]
you know what I was watching real sports
Bryant Gumbel Bryant Gumbel Brian
Gamble's real sports
Gumble I was watching his his show they
always said such a great show and they
was showing this guy that was on I want
to say he was on the Nationals and then
he says I'm good at two things you know
throwing a baseball and pissing people
off and I was thinking all right that's
it that's that's something a young
person says you know but then I actually
watched him and hey Nia you want to come
down and do the podcast for a second
talk about Bryant Gumbel
so anyways who were watching so it turns
out the kids actually like super super
super smart and he's doing all these
these you know he doesn't ice his arm
down like they've always told you to do
he does like what active recovery or
some [ __ ] like that yeah that little
stick that one thing come sit here so we
can we can we can hear yeah watch out
for my little [ __ ] my smoothie there
my almond smoothie yeah the belt was my
alt my belt was feeling a little tight
yesterday so anyway bryant gumbel right
bryant gumbel got the dad brain here so
we're watching this thing so we always
watch them they just have these amazing
stories and these guys go out in the
field and get the stories and then what
happens is inevitably is they come back
into the studio and they [ __ ] start
talking to Bryant Gumbel who for
whatever reason seems they have a
clipboard or some sort of pad of paper
legal pad yes seriously taking notes
like writing it down it's like right
what are you writing down the stories
over notes about like it's just so
preposterous I swear to god he's writing
man like what his assistant needs to get
him or like what he wants for dinner
that night or something I know cuz what
is he gonna go do a follow-up interview
what is he writing down like what this
glass is like just you know scribbling
it down and being like all right and
then I like how his diagnosis is the
diagnosis even if the guy says he is
don't you think he would you say he's a
little a little paranoid and the guy
goes I I would say he's a little
defensive so he's like yeah he goes yeah
a little
he goes so paranoid with a small pea
it's like yes Brian whatever you say yep
yeah write that down on your little
legal pad in a small piece it's your
shell
so whatever whatever you want it to be
sir you really crack me up we were just
sitting there watch it listen to story
and then Nia just looks ugly she goes
the [ __ ] is he writing down why is he
always writing down things possibly be
writing down it's like damn near a
scripted show like I don't understand
what the notes are about but I don't
know maybe he's that has to be the joke
with the prop people there when they
unlike we gotta get him his pad in his
pencil yeah maybe he is thinking of
follow-up stuff maybe he is watching
these segments for the first time and
then sitting down with the people but I
just don't I don't think that's true do
you know what that reminded me of
remember a long time ago when Dave
Letterman was out for a weekend he had
all those guest hosts and Will Ferrell
came in he hosted the show he was
amazing and then he just had this random
question you just be asking just normal
well you did this movie what was it like
and then I'll suggest I don't know a bit
how much you weigh and then you tell him
how much you weigh and then he would
just write it down and would never
address it and continued on and then
everybody on the show who came out he
asked them how much they weighed and
then Jake Johansen was the comedian that
night and Jake came out and you know and
when he did his intro hey how's
everybody going and then he looked over
and we'll and he goes 185 it was fun I'm
gonna get in trouble oh so it's okay
when a white guy randomly writes upped
it down yeah okay that's I just wanted
to talk about that I don't know do you
want to talk about the Bruins versus the
Calgary Flames the Celtics versus the
Utah Jazz again I'm at a loss blaming
generations for 200 Oh
blaming generations Oh like it's the
baby-boomers fault in that well some I
just heard something this morning that
stupid thing we listened we took a
lovely daughter to the doctor she's
awesome everything's going great thank
God and she's
just a general checkup for everybody
freaks out making sure she can you know
cognitive everything she has a check of
the facilities good
so you [ __ ] driving and we listen to
NPR cuz we're in Nia's car and Nia is
just so smart and just so loves
information so you know I've been
listening to - I've been listening to on
one of the Ramones what is it Johnny
Ramone the drummer he's like the only
guy left and he's got this great [ __ ]
show on Sirius I'll get you guys the
name of it he's called The Godfather and
he plays all of this [ __ ] killer
music from back then that I I never
listened to I was never into that [ __ ]
he plays like everything from the [ __ ]
that was going on UCB but like deep
tracks of all of those bands bands I
never heard of and then he did he did
this diss song by Black Flag called
slide it in and there's this little
snare drum fill in the beginning slide
it in it's a very it's not suggestive at
all not at all so there's a drum fill in
there and I was like oh my god I've
heard somebody do their variation of
that and it was Dave Grohl when he was
on Queens of the Stone Age I wonder if
that's where his not cuz I know he was
like a big punk drummer loved all the
punk drummers I mean and was in a punk
band and all that was into Bonham and
all of that stuff and remember whenever
you say was in a punk bands I just never
got into that [ __ ] so I'm listen to this
and I'm hearing all this great music
which is [ __ ] amazing it was really
good and then I heard this little drum
fill let me Dave did a whole drum solo
before it and then in the end he did
like I think he gave a little nod to
that guy which made a Vivaan cooler in
my book yeah so so anyway so no I got
off track so we're driving over to the
doctors and we're listening to NPR they
sing that song twenty Twenty twenty four
hours ago I wanna be sedated
Batman where to go oh I wanna be sedated
we started an awful band put me
something Oh Oh my brain whoa oh oh oh
my bap bap bap bap bap bap bap I want to
please sedate its gotta finish it bad
bad bad bad bad bad I wanna be sedated
me Rene he'll everybody thanks for
stopping by the podcast that would be
perfect edit there but I have to talk to
you about your pretentious NPR listening
I like him I like NPR but they were
talking about like this time during the
history of France that was the zones on
the done by a book which was kidding a
beautiful era right so they were talking
course they were focusing on all the
stuff that women did back then right
because it's NPR talking about the art
that was depicted at the time and some
of the art that was depicted of was of
the women doing domesticated work and
they were just describing how the
paintings in portraiture look but if the
descriptions here our newest thoughts
only and they're not shared by the
Monday morning podcast anything about
anything having to do with women without
you taking umbrage to it because you're
so [ __ ] fragile and your masculinity
admit anyone talks about anything women
are doing you're like Nia you are
ignoring I'm not saying that there's not
a lot of truth in that
all right but you did it nor it was they
were like showing all these paintings
they were going like they just show you
know how much of the workforce was women
back then like 30 percent of the
workforce was women and doing laundry
right and then [ __ ] go in there
talking about the woman iron and you
just see him putting their whole backs
into it
oh Jesus yeah meanwhile there was
probably 18 guys die in a day building
the [ __ ] Eiffel Tower competition
competition sexist it's not yeah you are
so are you am NOT no you were one of my
I love you love you Sam because right
my face beat it I have no use for you
of course you are course you are you're
a woman you came into a room you can't
leave without a parting gift isn't she
great you know she's not the brightest
bulb on the Christmas tree but you know
what I'll stick with it yeah it was
ridiculous they were like and you just
see these women they're just putting
their hope backs into it
and I just burst it out laughing big if
this goes back to the everybody [ __ ]
making fun of that flat earther who died
in the steam rocket you know all of you
[ __ ] people who just sit there and
you lay back and you let other people
take the risk and die and then they gain
the information and then they repeat it
to you and then you walk around like you
figured it out all right you didn't just
oh my god I [ __ ] hate when I do that
this doesn't seem a big deal to you but
I just I was trying to hit pause I don't
want to I was trying to see how much
time was left I hit the wrong button
then I had to stop I got a splice these
[ __ ] things together I tell you it is
so difficult to be a white male doing
his own podcast with no get Indiana
State remember all right
plowing ahead here let's see was I go
was it what was I gonna do here I just
completely lost my train of thought
bruins made a move I guess I missed it I
was working I was hoping we were gonna
get some [ __ ] lunatic to come up and
beat the [ __ ] out of those [ __ ]
one-dimensional st. Louis blows if we
meet him in the finals again
Bruins trae dead line acquisition look
at me with the big word where the [ __ ]
did that one come from all right Bruins
trade deadline moves affect Stanley
affect cap all right that missed me we
got rid of some lower paid people and
ended up with a higher salary
what Bruins trade deadline deal means
for their salary cap oh my god who the
[ __ ] cares it's been the company mantra
since dawn Sweeney took over as Bruins
general manager in the offseason of
2015 bruins has called the line between
winning and the president preserving the
future throughout the past four years
Jesus Christ who did they get I don't
know who they got let's just see if
they'd be Calgary and then I'll make my
decision on whether or not that was a
good move because that's what a sports
fan does first Bruins give me the score
Calgary five to toe we lost again
Christ week we traded away a guy went
hard for some flashy guy on the [ __ ]
ducks I blame him for this whole [ __ ]
one game losing streak since he's played
with us all right well we [ __ ] got
the [ __ ] kicked out of us we've led up
14 goals in the last two games all right
well this is good it's not bad it's not
bad to happen in February scares you
when it happens you know that's why he
hasn't season or whatever we're gonna
having good games everything's gonna be
fine and I believe the Celtics hung on
not hung on they will do they will like
up by seven I believe that's hanging on
hanging on to be Utah I don't know bill
why don't you get the [ __ ] score
before you start the podcast cuz that's
not how I do it all right I do have
something to promote here March 10th
March 10th everybody is at the Avalon
across from Capitol Records right here
in Hollywood it's gonna be this killer
show Dean Del Rey's putting together it
is a tribute to the 40th anniversary of
the passing of the late great arguably
greatest frontman in rock history Bon
Scott well one of the UK never see who's
a grace but he was one of just one of
the best coming out there right with his
tattoos back when badass guys got
tattoos no shirt on [ __ ] belt in the
songs out Angus going nuts
Malcolm cranking it out Mark Evans
cliff Williams depending on the era Phil
Rudd also a helicopter pilot also the
greatest [ __ ] drummer ever my opinion
as far as just [ __ ] making and taking
the easiest drum beat ever and making
80,000 people lose their [ __ ] minds
love that guy and I'd say you're very
underrated
CDC album is for those about to rock you
know came out a year after back in black
and then you know everybody gauges it by
album sales and I love that album and I
think it's it might be Phil runs best
drumming I love his drumming on that
album he got a little bit busier but was
still Phil Rudd and all of that stuff so
anyways it's gonna be a tribute to Bon
Scott so what it basically is it's a
stand-up show me and Deena doing
stand-up I imagine he'll have a couple
others full stand-up show and then he
comes out and basically does a [ __ ]
rock concert with all these [ __ ] rock
stars Nikki Nikki Sixx was there last
time Steve Gorman was there last time
just a whole bunch of people Jesus
Christ I'm blanking on everybody's
[ __ ] names scotty and from anthrax i
mean it was just a heavy lineup Dave
Kushner from Velvet Revolver who else
come on bill Oh yours truly I played
drums on a couple of songs and I'll play
drums on a couple this time it's gonna
be [ __ ] amazing come on down there's
rumors are some really [ __ ] big
people coming down drummers and all that
[ __ ] it's just everybody's got their
touring schedules but Dean knows all of
these guys so it's it's not going to be
you know not to [ __ ] on what me and Nia
just did to that Ramones song and I
apologize to all Ramone fans out there
but you know it's going to be
professionals except for the five
minutes while I'm playing all right so
okay plowing ahead here let's three the
artists simply safe everybody simply
safe with home security there's two ways
you can go about protecting your home
there's the traditional way where you
wait weeks for a technician to do a
messy installation that costs a small
fortune or there's the other way simply
safe simply safe is everything you need
in a home security system its
award-winning protection two-time winner
of a cien et Editors Choice Award simply
safe blankets your whole home in safety
you get comprehensive protection for
your infernal your entire home outdoor
camera and doorbells are alerting you to
anyone approaching your home entry
motion and glass break sensors guard in
side you barely notice it's there but
what's truly remarkable is you can set
up this system all by yourself yes you
it takes 30 minutes to an hour tops and
there's absolutely no trade-offs to your
safety you'll have an army of highly
trained security experts ready to
dispatch police to your home and a
moment's notice
24/7 and it's only 50 cents a day with
no contracts it's why the verge calls
simply safe the best home security
system visit simply safe bur combi URR
you'll get free shipping and a 60-day
risk-free trial you'll get you got
nothing to lose
go now and be sure you go to simply
safer calm that's simply safe BER calm
all right all right let's get on to what
I wanted to talk about here
blaming generations and I'll tell you
right now you there's no other way to
know that somebody is going to [ __ ]
be pontificating than to know that a big
phony guy who lives in Hollywood who has
his own podcast is about ready to take a
sip of an almond smoothie ok so you
should know the amount of
pretentiousness that is coming your way
so I don't want to hear any [ __ ]
complaints about all bill you went out
to Hollywood you got [ __ ] soft but
but we all know this I'm in Hollywood
right now doing a podcast so full of
myself that I don't even have guests
unless my wife walks by and I'm in a
good mood
ok I've crossed one leg over the other
and I have an almond smoothie in my hand
ok and now I'm gonna drink it and try to
tell you guys why you need to be doing
what I'm doing is if you all admire me
physically oh is that good I'll tell you
I actually prefer this to cow's milk I
like when people going you know we're
the only species I think I've said this
before we're the only species that
[ __ ] nurses from a from a different
species and I saw a picture the other
day I don't know what these [ __ ]
things were but they didn't look like
foxes and they were hanging from a fox
so
I don't know they look like a bunch of
[ __ ] one of those things like back in
the day they would walk by a heater and
just catch on fire is it gerbils I don't
[ __ ] know I don't pretend to know
things people I just keep talking and
just hoping hoping that something will
make sense at the end of all this
alright so when we were listening to NPR
there was a commercial or something like
that well they don't really have
commercials on that I think it was a
different station at that point they're
like are you blah blah blah
are you disappointed with the decisions
that the generations made before you I
think that's such a [ __ ] ignorant
statement in generations once again is
just another way to take a group of
humans and then create and us and of em
all right it is a disease in the human
brain I do it look at me I can't even
listen on NPR when they're talking about
a bunch of women who are now dead
washing clothes and ironing in society
where I think all women belong by the
way I'm kidding but you had to emit you
guys were really good at it um you know
if you were if you if you weren't good
at it then guys would be doing am i
right come on back me up this guy knows
what I'm talking about
with the Hawaiian shirt in the [ __ ]
toupee okay no they're always like is
this us and they think and rather than
group and people like to sit there and
act like I guess with them with pop
culture and technology there's
definitely a you know you don't remember
that show or I've never heard of this
that isn't music there's definitely that
[ __ ] but just as far as behavior I think
it's ignorant to do that because then
you can just be like these [ __ ] baby
boomers man they said they were all
about peace they all became the same
[ __ ] bank accounts that melted down
the economy 50 [ __ ] years later right
40 years later what am I trying to say
here yeah it's just like
you know every generation is just you're
just gonna have greedy psychotic
lunatics that [ __ ] ascend to power
and I don't think there's any stopping
it I don't know how do you do that
because as much as I don't want that to
happen I don't know how to test people
to make sure they're actually decent
people by the way I really wish I've
been watching the debates with everybody
screaming - yelling each other as far as
like the highlights go I think I like
Bernie Sanders and I like Elizabeth
Warren you know there's just something
great about like people of a certain age
who just have that vibe like you know
I'm not taking any [ __ ] from you they
still have passion they still got fire
I like those guys the screaming and
yelling and talking all over each other
it's just like wow if people wanted to
hear that they just listen to my podcast
when I have a guest alright anyway so
I'm not blaming [ __ ] generations it's
fun to do it I do like that they blame
generations because being part of
Generation X is fantastic because we're
just like you know nobody even remembers
us somehow we're not a part of the
global warming we're not a part of the
banking's like no Generation X person
ever says [ __ ] the drinking water I'm
doing whatever it takes to ascend this
[ __ ] corporation I mean we're every
generation has those [ __ ] people so
but what's great is right now
Generation X we just sit nestled in
between baby boomers and Millennials I
think isn't is there another generation
between Generation X and then
Millennials I don't even know I don't
even know but all I know is they're
taking all the [ __ ] heat right they
like the houston astros right now
they're takin all the [ __ ] heat all
the heat that people just cannot some
guy in sports radio I listened to it was
just sitting there saying like this is
the biggest conspiracy in modern time
it's just like in far as far as what
sports
it's not even in sports
you don't think it was a bigger
conspiracy when they were losing fans to
all the other sports in baseball that
they conspired to blackmail cities into
by making them new stadiums that they
then design them so that the offense
would would be would be greater because
that's what seemed to be selling the
games of basketball in football more
point-scoring they didn't do sup the
ball bring the outfield walls in am I
crazy am I crazy
the owners didn't look the other way
when they knew everybody was doing
steroids and cranking him out of the
park but attendance was higher than ever
and the President of the United States
Bill Clinton was sitting there watching
the homerun [ __ ] competition between
Sammy Sosa and Mark McGwire right it
wasn't a conspiracy to keep it an
all-white league for as long as [ __ ]
humanly possible what the [ __ ] are you
talking about the owners didn't conspire
back before free agents three two [ __ ]
up everybody you not go past a certain
number as much as they possibly could
yeah I don't know what they're talking
about somehow the Houston Astros banging
on a [ __ ] trash can that's the
biggest that's the most sophisticated
conspiracy that's ever happened in
baseball I don't know and then I'll I
always love when people go like well if
you're gonna [ __ ] do that if these
guys could do that and they can still go
over there and Pete it always goes there
Pete Rose you're being the [ __ ] Hall
of Fame they're people um they don't
seem to remember how that whole Pete
Rose thing went down all right he broke
the number one [ __ ] rule in baseball
which is you don't [ __ ] gamble on it
because that [ __ ] with everybody
because as much as the Houston Astros
cheated or whatever and did their
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know that doesn't
affect all of baseball people are just
mad at the Houston Astros in a buying
tickets so when they come to town so
they can go
cheater right as as you go around that
line waiting to make the right turn and
at the last second you cut into the line
and you [ __ ] over everybody behind cuz
you don't want to wait now you're gonna
yell cheater these two anyway say yell
cheater those [ __ ] people right it
doesn't affect the whole [ __ ] game if
anything it's great publicity
everybody's talking baseball everybody
wants to see what's gonna happen and
watch Altuve and all these guys
squirming in their [ __ ] interviews
alright what happened the reason why
Pete Rose got punished to the level that
he did was because of the 1919 White Sox
and they always call him the Black Sox
because they threw the 1919 World Series
they call him the Black Sox which it was
weird because it doesn't make it seem
like they were the Chicago White Sox
they weren't the Black Sox they make it
seem like it was some [ __ ] you know
Negro League team or some [ __ ] it was
the White Sox all white people on the
White Sox in 1919 they threw the [ __ ]
World Series and the league was early on
and it made people think that the whole
thing was [ __ ] or at least they were
worried that they were and that would
[ __ ] with all these millionaires at the
time I don't know what they were worth
back then you probably just had five
grand you probably considered a [ __ ]
wealthy man back then it [ __ ] with the
whole business model and it took someone
like Babe Ruth coming along to save the
sport so that became like we could never
have a scandal like this again and then
Pete Rose went out and did it and then
he denied it categorically for like 20
years 25 years and then when he finally
admitted to it
he goes alright I gambled on baseball
now let me in the hall that was his
apology there's a thing I think Pete
Rose should be in the Hall of Fame I
definitely think he should be in the
Hall of Fame that you punished the guy
the guy absolutely loves baseball he has
a gambling problem he [ __ ] up he paid
the price
you should definitely I definitely think
they should let him in but I don't think
the houston astros thing if they let
these guys go that that's like Pete Rose
I just don't because what Pete Rose did
was at mean I don't think it would have
affected the entire game but it's it's
more of how baseball looks at that
offense they equate it to what you did
what the [ __ ]
1919 White Sox did which almost took
down the whole sport or they were afraid
that was gonna so that's why they've
been such sticklers with that and then
also you had a commissioner I think that
in his dying wish or something is
probably that's probably just a [ __ ]
theory an urban myth you know wanted
people to adhere to that because I think
it got personal between the two of them
and he just wouldn't admit it and bla
bla bla bla bla they had to do all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] so anyways I don't have
said so I think what I'm saying is you
can't blame generations Pete Rose [ __ ]
up he should have been punished they
should stick him in the Hall of Fame now
um your friends not a narcissist he's
just into himself but he's not a full-on
[ __ ] narcissist alright and you know
someone can you know [ __ ] kill an ant
with a magnifying glass and they're not
a sociopath the other potential like a
boss I don't know and I'm liking the
older Democratic candidate wouldn't be
[ __ ] great to see Elizabeth Warren
and Donald Trump not listening to each
other and just yelling at each other at
Donald Trump and [ __ ] Bernie Sanders
wouldn't you know who neppy wouldn't be
a fitting end to this country just the
two of them yelling at each other two
old white guys I could see a net wolf
whatever the [ __ ] that they would be
saying to each other and beef animal I'm
weird like that alright I didn't think I
said a [ __ ] thing in the last [ __ ]
five minutes and I apologize but I hope
I got you through your traffic all right
god bless you I'm gonna finish my
smoothie and stare at myself in the
mirror cuz I'm a big phony here in
Hollywood god bless you guys thanks for
listening to the podcast I got a little
bit of music here picked out by the
great Andrew chthamalus and then a bonus
half-hour audition from a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts from a few years ago
alright get those tickets from March
10th at the Avalon
watch old Billy freckles banging out the
drums there for a couple songs and a
bunch of rock stars and Dean Del Ray
hey what's going on it's bill burr it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
February 27th 2012 how the hell are you
how's it going I in a good mood I hope
you are Jesus Christ I'm [ __ ] brain
dead this week I just did two shows that
the comedy works I'm still in Denver I
was as I'm recording this here and I'm
laying in the hotel bed I'm wearing a
t-shirt bike jockey
I'm wearing jockey right now Calvin
Klein boxers and jockey pajama bottoms
that's what I'm wearing this is my
tribute to the Oscars you know who you
wearing would you guys like to do that
would you like to be at the Oscars you
know walk it down yeah what are you
wearing you know I would I'd love to be
at the Oscars right now sitting there
waiting to accept my third best male
[ __ ] supporting no lead lead guy and
set the record remember Tom Hanks almost
set the record he won two years in a row
and they went for the third when he
played the astronaut I thought he had it
he ran the gamut you know we won in
nineteen like 90-something right right
he played the gay guy that nobody liked
cuz he had the disease that everybody
wasn't scared of all right and what did
he do he hate a bunch of kale salad he
lost weight he looked like Michael Stipe
that's what I thought
right and if you believe you get aids
from shaking my hand all right did he
sing that song shake it and then he won
he won an Oscar for that a [ __ ] Oscar
and then the next year he played the
mentally challenged first and waiting
for the bus eating the chocolate bars I
completely didn't understand that
movie and I suffered for a long time
because of that movie because it was it
was one of those impressions somebody
figured out how to do it and then
everybody could just kind of do it right
at some point in their act they had to
be like I love you Jen a right I had to
listen to that for [ __ ] seven years
seven years waiting for the final couple
of hacks to stop [ __ ] doing one of
those goddamn jokes alright so there you
go he played a mentally challenged guy
he played Michael Stipe look-alike but
it wasn't Michael all right and then the
next year he plays an astronaut houston
we have a problem right bat bat bat now
he's got the [ __ ] American flag
draped around him and somehow he didn't
win it you know just didn't make any
[ __ ] sense I don't know I'm not
watching the Oscars tonight I should
probably have it on should I I missed
the whole [ __ ] thing up I don't I
don't like watching award shows watching
an award show that's like going to like
your little brother's graduation you
don't give a [ __ ] just give my brother
the thing and so I can get the [ __ ] out
of here right you know I usually like
going to Oscar parties cuz I just go
there and I and I ruin it for everybody
else because I sit there trashing people
[Music]
you know trashing these way more
successful people than I am you know
it's ridiculous
god I love doing a [ __ ] Oscar go up
there and act like I'm humble you know I
just don't even feel like I mean what I
just think of all the work that
everybody else did so that I can stand
here and just be me me me this is
awesome if I ever win one I'm not gonna
be humble well that'd be [ __ ]
hilarious if you had the balls to just
go up there just walking up there and
the arts get goes so bill burr for
redheads or people too stupid music and
then I go up there and I just [ __ ]
take it out of some broads hand yeah you
know what it's about [ __ ] time all
you are the goddamn group's [ __ ]
moaning and complaining
you know it's about time they let it
read it and Mail be an action arrow
sons-of-bitches all these years all the
gay people complaining all the ladies
all the black people what about the
redheads you know what this isn't for
all the other redheads this is for me
it's about [ __ ] time
go [ __ ] yourselves all of you you [ __ ]
up you gave me a million dollars and I
didn't spend any of it so you know what
I don't need any of you I'm out of here
all right I bought some land in Wyoming
I got a [ __ ] gun and I'm not doing it
over these [ __ ] movies because I
don't like doing it nine times in a row
okay could we do it again hey can you go
[ __ ] yourself yeah the cameras on you
saw it didn't you why do all you wear
those giant glasses with the black
frames you know thanks to you guys doing
that now LeBron James is doing it and
that [ __ ] guy on the Kevin Durant
everybody's got these bid
what's-his-face the other guy Dwight
Howard's wearing those big [ __ ]
glasses why are all the NBA superstars
dressing like old casting directors oh
wait back to the acceptance speech all
right so [ __ ] all you and that's it
Merry Christmas that's my acceptance
speech you know all you just need to win
one no matter how much of a douche you
are for the rest of your life you're
like that
that's the Oscar winning douche bag bill
burr that's got to be right up there
right the Oscars basically the Medal of
Honor for [ __ ] you know you didn't
take out a platoon I'll hold out a
[ __ ] platoon all by yourself
you didn't run up to a tank and drop her
grenade in it what did you do you
pretended to be a guy who ran up to a
tank and dropped a grenade into the
[ __ ] thing right I don't even know
what I'm talking about people I had two
shows tonight the
first one was at four o'clock this
afternoon right because his people had
to get home to watch the Oscars why your
tits look like prunes eat something
how you like me people do you like a
little [ __ ] girl with little meat on
her bones you know I mean some of you
can [ __ ] throw around the bedroom
isn't that isn't that lovely
um what am I talking about this week
what are we talking about hey everybody
you know what how about a nice little
it´s time for commercial everybody doo
doo doo doo doo doo but up up and up up
hey do you guys like going to the post
office well go ahead I don't care I
don't have to go to the post office
anymore I don't feel like going to
school I don't go to the post office
anymore I'm done standing in that damn
line buying all those miserable people
just to get up to the front to have
somebody say next window please and then
watch them sit their fat ass and a bunch
of those peanuts that they put in the
box you know and their stupid blue pants
I've had it I don't like their uniforms
I don't like the looks on their faces
wouldn't it be phenomenal if somebody
came up way to bring the post office
into your house into your apartment into
your tent if you're out there down still
down there in wall street right what
they call if you're taking over what was
it called occupy if you're occupying
someplace you need to write you need to
send out a bunch of mass email all you
got to do is go to stamps calm everybody
all right your time is valuable you
don't have time to go down there and
stand with all those other miserable
bastards all right you want to print out
the stamps by yourself when that be
great this is like this is like the the
what do they call it the center ice
package you want to watch all the NHL
games you get that all right this is the
center ice package for [ __ ] stamps
why did I just curse and ruin this Reed
I don't know that's what I do i
self-sabotage but that doesn't mean I
don't believe
Prada cuz I use it alright this is just
going off the rails here stamps.com it's
so convenient let's get back to the copy
buy and print official US postage using
your own computer and printer you can
print postage for any letter or package
whenever you need it 24/7 24/7 people
I'm mailing out all my DVDs they give me
a little scale I love it I feel like I'm
a little kid pretending to work at the
post office but I'm actually an adult
with a real post office basically in my
own apartment my own house excuse me
alright so I know what you're thinking
you just like me you're selfish like
okay bill that's great what's in it for
me where's the special offer where's the
buy one get one free well here it comes
there Freddie right now stamps.com has a
special offer from my listeners my
listeners it's a no risk trial no risk
okay you get $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale that you're
gonna love by the way you're gonna get
addicted to using it like me and you get
fifty five dollars in free postage
alright this is a no risk trial they
giving you fifty five bucks and a little
scale
alright so sit your Fanny on the scale
and lick those stamps baby because this
is a hell of a deal but only if you go
and you use my last name this is what
you do you go to stamps calm before you
do anything else once you get to the
website you click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
you type in BRR be is and BRR you are
are okay that's stance calm enter Brooke
get your stamps get your scale and never
stand in that miserable miserable bread
line that there's no bread at the front
all right how is that for a REIT alright
let's get on to stuff that I want to I
want to [ __ ] about this week alright I
know a lot of you guys you probably
think on some level then I hate women
alright I gotta be honest with you you
[ __ ] right I don't like hate him
individually but as a group they [ __ ]
annoy me because they're always
complaining [ __ ] moaning and all this
[ __ ] crap unlike me who just always
brings to sunshine
hi this is the thing whenever it comes
down to male-female relationships what
I've noticed on television is that if
someone's gonna be the douche it's
always the guy if somebody's at fault
it's always the guy if somebody's it's
always the guy except for the occasional
Britney Spears alright who if I ever see
I'm buying her a [ __ ] beer poor girl
with that bum ass husband right backup
dancer sitting around the house getting
fat sitting in sweat pants that she paid
for you know she ever went over there
and slapped the [ __ ] out of him
smashed him on his head with one of her
bedazzled high heels and I was on that
jury I would say not guilty I would say
not guilty I would say she's a [ __ ]
hero that she hasn't done it yet because
he has a story for you these are the
stories I'm just gonna put this out here
because I'm really hoping that this is
gonna inspire somebody to start some
sort of legislation or whatever the [ __ ]
you need to do to turn things around
because I really in this country there's
a major problem women are organized and
guys are not when it comes to this
relationship [ __ ] all right oh you go
right ahead and roll your eyes ladies I
don't give a [ __ ] this isn't for you all
right there's a nice story yes Murray
one of these every [ __ ] week two
[ __ ] people realize what is going on
all right what is not not what is going
on what is also going on is every
[ __ ] three minutes I gotta watch the
story about some poor woman who got the
living [ __ ] kicked out of her by some
[ __ ] guy right and you watch enough
for those stories and you start thinking
oh my god women are always the victim
that's not so here's a nice story for
you a little story called who knew I was
not the father do I even need to read it
to you you know where this is going this
happens all the [ __ ] time but it they
they don't talk about it you know it's
not considered a major [ __ ] problem
it's because guys are not organized and
we have to start [ __ ] moaning and
complaining the way women do all right
just mentally try and imagine what it's
like to have a period and that's the
mindset you need to get in to make
change in this country that's what I
think that's what I think is needed
alright ok here we are boys and girls
gather round who knew I was not the
father
take one it was July in 2007 when Mike
and uh Mike L asked the Pennsylvania
courts to declare that he was no longer
the father of his daughter for four
years Mike had known that the girl he
had rocked to sleep and dance with
across the living room floor was not as
they say his the revelation from a DNA
test was devastating and prompted him to
leave his wife but he had not renounced
their child because he's a good [ __ ] cuz
he realized that the kid you know it's
not the kids fault that her mom is a
[ __ ] you know this guy's a stand-up guy
but he had not renounced a child
he continued to feel that in all the
ways that mattered she was still his
daughter and he faithfully paid her
child support this guy he's a saint if
there's a god this guy is going straight
into heaven okay he could have been
bitter he could have walked away he
didn't stood in right so was only when
he learned that his ex-wife was about to
marry the man who she said actually was
the girl's biological father that Mike
flipped supporting another's man's child
suddenly became unbearable can you
believe this woman why don't they show
that why don't they say it's showing all
these stories of guys beating women what
about a woman why don't they show when
women do [ __ ] like this you know not
only did she cheat on her husband she
[ __ ] a dude raw not only did she [ __ ]
the dude raw she let him bust it in him
not only did she have a [ __ ] kid with
them she didn't say [ __ ] to her husband
so they make this [ __ ] guy he has to
find out he's sitting there you know
looking how he looks and his kid doesn't
look anything like him and she doesn't
say [ __ ] so one day goes to Walgreens
gets a little DNA test does a little
swab e swab of her and then him sends it
off - you got to be [ __ ] me Labs in
[ __ ] Colorado
comes back finds out it's not his kid
he's
absolutely [ __ ] devastating his
goddamn marriage is over
and he's still a stand-up guy so now
this [ __ ] [ __ ] goes back with the
guy that actually knocked her up now
they're living together okay wouldn't
you think despite the fact that she's a
[ __ ] that maybe she wouldn't be a [ __ ]
too you know it's unbelievable why not
at that point just have the [ __ ] real
dad pay and if for some reason the
courts are making this guy go through
the motions or write in the cheque just
take the cheque cash it and give it back
to the guy why can't you do that you
know why cuz they can never have enough
do you know how guys can never have
enough [ __ ] women can never have enough
stuff you ever notice that even if they
have a one-night stand they still got to
get a t-shirt you know they always got
to get something I don't know if I've
said that before in this podcast but
it's [ __ ] true they always gotta have
stuff you know and he's they got this
free [ __ ] money coming and this [ __ ]
has got to she's pimping these guys
she's got two guys two guys working for
goddamn genius also a [ __ ] but she's a
genius of a [ __ ] okay I mean how dumb is
that guy who actually knocked her up how
dumb is he to marry her
who the [ __ ] marries somebody who was on
who marries who makes somebody their
wife who was already somebody else's
wife and [ __ ] around with you you saw
what she did you think she's not gonna
get tired of you you think she's not
gonna go somewhere else get some more
dick in a little more you know foreign
spackle between the [ __ ] gams
unbelievable say you go that's Jen
that's not misogynistic that I'm only
reason reading these stories what I'm
doing is I'm trying to balance out the
[ __ ] that you see it on TV the
[ __ ] vibe that only guys cheat guys
are dogs
guys guys guys do all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's okay we are equal okay we
are equal we are capable of doing
wonderful things like this guy who did
the right thing by this little girl and
we're also capable doing horrific things
all right slapping the [ __ ] out of
[ __ ] women stay
their heads in the glovebox try and see
if you can get it all the way closed you
know
we also do [ __ ] like that and ladies
right they can be absolute angels and
they can be a steaming pile of [ __ ] like
this woman so there you go that's my
little fair and balanced reporting for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves I've done
it I've done to our two and a half hours
of comedy tonight my new special I'm
taping this Saturday night at the
Lincoln Theater in Washington DC and let
me tell you something brother I'm
[ __ ] bringing it on this one all
right I am on a mission to outdo my last
two [ __ ] specials okay and I don't
care if you [ __ ] don't think I did it I
think I'm gonna do it all right I have a
special is it even a special at this
point now that Comedy Central has given
every [ __ ] person on the planet a
goddamn special I'm gonna call this one
it's a stand-up standard you know
everybody I can't believe half my
listeners haven't gotten an hour-long
special on Comedy Central you know God
bless Comedy Central they put me on
forever but I got to tease them a little
bit the year when I did my half-hour if
you guys ever see if you ever get a
chance to watch my half hour that music
that they played when they went to the
commercial was it was the worst music
I've ever heard in my life
it was so [ __ ] disrespectful to all
the hard work he did as a comedian you
finally get a special you're excited and
then they just would go to commercial
and they'd have your face and there was
just this trumpet that would go what
they have lyrics to that yes yeah [ __ ]
you then that's what it sounded like
look at this wacky douchebag that's just
you know what I mean there's just no
respect for it
so anyways I'm taping this special I'm
doing two on
- on Saturday night and I am beyond
[ __ ] ready I worked my ass off for
the last six weeks I've done a bunch of
shows and I really want to thank
everybody who came out and sincerely
laughed at what was funny and [ __ ]
stare to me when it wasn't because I got
this [ __ ] it's it's ready to go it's
ready to go man but I'm not gonna lie to
you I'm [ __ ] wiped out this is what
this is what I did all right
I'm taping it in DC I live in Los
Angeles okay do the nautical [ __ ]
miles there it's a horrific flight that
I've done a zillion [ __ ] times all
right right I'm [ __ ] over it Mike
yeah
so I bought a coach ticket and then
[ __ ] use my miles which is something
I never do I never use my miles don't
ask me why I just keep I keep I get a
bunch of miles I never [ __ ] use them
and then the airline gets bought out by
somebody else and then somebody comes in
they say hey you know what you don't
have any more miles and I say well guess
what they're [ __ ] Rapunzel I I never
use them so go [ __ ] yourself all right
you got anything else to tell me you
don't [ __ ] call me up and tell me
what I have and I don't have I have
enough in my life and I don't need you
or you [ __ ] miles all right
go [ __ ] yourself so so I actually used
my miles
I bumped myself up to a first-class
[ __ ] ticket all right and I'm going
out there stone [ __ ] sober and when I
come back I'm drinking on that flight
baby and they're probably gonna have to
land in st. Louis because I might be the
next guy to take a [ __ ] on the food cart
that's how drunk I am gonna get because
I have done so many shows if I have to
do this hour one more [ __ ] time I'm
gonna kill myself
I'll be fine by next Saturday nobody
wants to bomb when the cameras are on
so that nervousness you know but as far
as this hour I absolutely love it but
I'm walking away after this week I've
had it I'm walking away like De Niro and
heat
and then I then I get to start the
wonderful process of a whole new [ __ ]
hour with everything that I've learned
from this hour so I want to thank
everybody who's gone out and bought
tickets and all that type of [ __ ] and
everyone who's gone to amazon.com it's
[ __ ] blowing up man you guys are doing
such a wonderful thing for me for the
people who other people who were a
person who works on my podcasts I'm able
to pay him now nice amount of money and
then 10% of everything that goes to
amazon.com is going to the Wounded
Warriors Project and which is leading me
to have a nice relationship with them
which is gonna lead to more cool stuff
so thank you so if you're new to my
podcast this is basically it if you go
on amazon.com if you're gonna buy
something I'm not saying the [ __ ] buy
anything relax but if you're going to
just go to my part on my podcast go to
my website first go to billboard.com
click on the podcast on the right-hand
side you'll see the link to amazon.com
right underneath the itunes you click on
that and then I'll get credit for
driving traffic there they'll give me a
little bit of kickback it doesn't cost
you a [ __ ] thing right they give me a
little bit of a kickback and then I take
10% of that give it to the wounded
warriors so you donate to my podcast and
you help out veterans who fought for
this country all right and you get a
free [ __ ] podcast and whatever the
hell you bought on amazon.com I mean
Jesus Christ how much more do you need
to win you know God some people are so
selfish somebody's actually sitting here
right now gone is that it is that all I
get
you know and if you are be that way I
don't give a [ __ ] how far Enright 23
goddamn minutes 23 minutes into this
podcast um alright I had I had an
unbelievable weekend out here at the
Denver Comedy Works I didn't booze until
Saturday night boost one time friend
came by I made some new friends and we
drank not too crazy you know a couple
two or three couple two or three shots
you know a little surf and turf as they
say yeah uh then I came home I called
the lovely Neil my a was going on she's
like you've been drinking Avenue
drunk anyways last week I talked about
those noise cancellation headphones and
I had questions about him you know my
ears have [ __ ] up from playing drums
and you know I wanted to get those noise
cancellation things and I had a question
about as far as like if you're wearing
those are they actually protecting your
ears are they just tricking your ears
into thinking they're not hearing
anything but they actually are hearing
it but they can't register it so you're
still [ __ ] up yours so somebody who I
don't know what their background is is
putting me at ease says bill just in
case no one has answered this question
adequately yes the answer is no noise
cancellation will not [ __ ] up your ears
well this guy sounds like a pro the
principle behind noise cancellation is
called destructive interference the
destructive part is the key here
applying one sound wave which is out of
phase with another will quite literally
neutralize the sound producing a dead or
quiet zone so it's not that you just
can't hear the noise that is messing up
your ears it's that it isn't there at
all anymore
well [ __ ] it I want to get some who
makes the best once let me know tell me
who makes them and I will buy them and
I'm gonna start asking more of these
questions cuz I have one for you I fly
all the [ __ ] time and you know what
was killing me is that there's no more
supersonic jets whatever happened to
those Conchords can you like buy the
other ones that didn't crash off of ebay
you know they got to be sitting
somewhere some billionaire probably has
it can you imagine that if you had a
private jet the size of a commercial jet
and it could [ __ ] fly at supersonic
speed you know that was a dream of mine
that never happened I always wanted to
fly to Paris on the Concord
you know I wanted to be there and hear
that [ __ ] you know when you break the
speed of sound what is that wall of
vapor that forms right when you break
the speed of sound can somebody explain
that to me that is just like that's the
closest thing that I've ever seen to
anything in Star Wars like literally
being true the fact that you that you go
faster than sound you think think about
I mean what speed of lights the next one
I mean that's a huge [ __ ] jump but
that's [ __ ] unbelievable what it why
does why do you know I'm too [ __ ]
stupid even ask the question you know
what I'm asking could somebody help me
with my scientific background I really
would like to be able to explain [ __ ] I
just don't understand it maybe I should
just remain ignorant so much of the
world just seems magical to me because I
don't understand basic laws of physics
like how a plane stays up in the air I
just I just don't understand it it's
heavier than I am I can't fly you know
don't even send me a [ __ ] email about
lift and surfing on the air I I don't
get it it's just something I'm never
gonna understand alright last week we
talked about a shitty neighborhood be a
short podcast everybody man I don't know
what uh I don't know what to talk about
I'm burnt out
shitty neighbor and how I handled it hey
Bill and the lovely Nia loved the
podcast my wife and I have an awful
downstairs neighbor that has a long
history of randomly threatening people
much like the [ __ ] neighbor in last
week's podcast we ignored him until one
day he banged on the floor and scared
the piss out of my sweet little
mother-in-law who was visiting yeah they
always seem to like to pick on women you
know [ __ ] [ __ ] I stood for an hour
until my mother-in-law left and I went
down there and basically dared this guy
to punch me that's awesome because he
has to hit you first as you note it
that's right that's right but I don't
know what happens if you ask somebody to
punch him in the face then I mean isn't
he just kind of helping you out there I
don't know there's so much [ __ ] I don't
understand obviously he didn't do
anything because he's a fat creep who
sweats butter that's why I had the
confidence to challenge someone to
fisticuffs for the first time since
grade school so nothing happened just a
lot of yelling but he didn't but he did
sputter next time I see you I'm gonna
kick your [ __ ] ass oh I love that
next time I see you what are you busy
right now fatty
what do you got to do what you got a
couple more [ __ ] stay comes on the
stove you don't want to burn there's
nothing better than beating up a fatty
cuz it doesn't even hurt your hands you
know he's sitting there wheezing you
just feel like you're beating up a
beanbag
you know it's tremendous I'm not
advocating it I'm not advocating beating
down the obese I'm just saying to do it
if they're [ __ ] if you want to it's
your choice ladies and gentlemen
so anyways so I started laughing and he
slammed the door in my face that's
perfect next time I see him he kicked my
ass he just laughs in his face oh that
poor fat bastard I bet he went in there
ate a burger while watching a porno
jerking off he was so depressed um so
when her I see him now I stop and laugh
and ask him is it time for you to kick
my ass tough guy
wow this guy's brilliant I hope the
person from last week is listening
because this guy this guy's doing it
he's doing it perfectly
he says I've even seen him hide in his
car to avoid talking to me so your
advice bill has worked great oh it's my
advice wait a minute I did I read this
wrong did you just [ __ ] do this
look at this did I help this guy out
thank God so laughing is working out for
this guy um what the [ __ ] is it nice oh
Jesus Christ then we scrolled down come
on bill
so we look at him now I stopped and
asked him as a time keep your hands but
today oh he says tough guy is the key
phrase because it's so condescending as
for Nia's advice to win the heart and
mind of the guy's wife which I also
thought was great my neighbor has a high
school-aged kid that sometimes visits I
don't know what the relation is but
whenever I see this kid playing soccer
outside I say hello crack a joke
ask him about Real Madrid because he
always wears their gear these twenty
second these twenty second conversation
Drive my neighbor nuts I can see him
pairing out the window as oh dude you're
killing this guy the neighbor has been
emasculated neutralized the cops never
got involved and I never even had to
ground
with the greasy retiree Billy Nia eople
perfect advice no wonder you guys is
such a good pair ah wasn't that nice
dude this guy killed it I don't know if
we told you all that last week I think I
think you had a natural talent for that
so there you go
laughing calling somebody tough guy ah
what I love is you've made this guy's
life so miserable that not only does he
not even knocking on the ceiling anymore
he's now he actually hides from you oh
and the shame so you know what that
means is this guy fantasizes about what
he wishes he could do to you when he
can't which makes him even more
miserable which probably makes him eat
more
which makes him fatter you know which is
one day gonna neutralize the entire
problem because he's gonna be too fat to
lift that roast beef of a [ __ ] arm up
to even hit the ceiling
you know Wow
anyways through my lips are so [ __ ]
dry right now it's ridiculous and I'm
one of those guys that believes in that
urban myth that if you use chapstick
there's something in there that makes
you addicted to it and that you what
your lips you know it's like if you're
constipated you know what I mean
and you keep taking those pills so you
can [ __ ] if you do it too much your body
just goes oh we don't need to make
whatever the [ __ ] it is that we make to
make you you know be able to [ __ ] and
then you got to take you know you never
take you know if you're constipated you
never take those pills it's very simple
you just do what all the Romans used to
do it all right you wade into a stream
all right you face your ass upriver you
stick a reed up your ass and you fill
your ass with river water all right you
know that doesn't clean out your system
then you you weren't meant to [ __ ] ever
again okay and the great thing is it's
all natural that's what the ice now
actually they used to do that's what
they used to do when before when they
would they needed like an enema or what
do they call that when people
have a colonic they used to do that back
in the day that's how they did it back
in the days they took a [ __ ] if they
took a read they waited in the river
they had their ass pointed towards the
current and then they jam to read up
there just stood there and just accepted
as much as the river up their asses they
could and then they just they just fine
you know [ __ ] confetti going down the
river you know and that was probably the
first environmental disaster see people
you got to know your history or else
you'd doomed to repeat it
oh god 33 minutes in yes oh my [ __ ]
lips are uh I've been using this [ __ ]
since last week cuz last week when I was
in New York I was driving all the gigs
and was cold out so I had the heat on
and rather than having it on defrost is
what I usually do I had the vent on and
I dried out my lips so I bought this
[ __ ] and ever since ever since I bought
it it's like my [ __ ] lips keep drying
out and I keep using it and drinking
plenty of water you know I'm telling you
I really believe in that so uh you know
[ __ ] chapstick all right that's reverse
advertising everybody [ __ ] that one in
its age all right more advice hey Bill
buying a car by the way huh Grey's the
advice now now that we finally stop with
the relationship stuff I'll eventually
come back to it but you know I'll give
you guys moronic advice on it on
everything and once again you're on your
own okay I'm not an expert on any of
this [ __ ]
all right buying a car dear bill I'm a
19 year old Taekwondo instructor and
full-time student in Queens College
I live in blah blah blah blah and my
dojo is that a spell dojo doj aan doe
Jan I don't know I'm gonna say dojo
because that's what I've always heard
dojo and College couldn't be farther
apart I recently bought a Mazda Protege
year 2000 from my aunt Oh God never
never buy a [ __ ]
shitbox from a relative it's never gonna
end good I don't like the way this is
going already
I had it recently in the shop for the
entire first month and it was officially
mine and I did over $2,000 of repair new
suspension rear brakes sensors etc the
[ __ ] sensors I don't even know what
about cars anymore
on it in order for it to hopefully cut
down on my travel time and last a couple
of good years it broke down in Long
Island after the first full month of use
[ __ ] me so I wanted to ask you if you
had any advice on another car it could
by where I could look to buy one that
won't [ __ ] me that won't [ __ ] me over
because seriously [ __ ] family and any
tips you could give me on saving for the
car would be greatly appreciated yeah
dude
I don't know what it is about family
it's like they love you and they have
your back except when it comes to
selling you a car cuz they will [ __ ] you
over I saw it when I was a kid you know
I just it's I don't know what it is they
just first of all you're buying it from
your aunt she's older they don't know
[ __ ] and they think it's a great I don't
know or maybe they just completely [ __ ]
you over this is what I was this is what
this is what I do when I when I bought
used cars is don't buy anything flashy
cuz it's got this [ __ ] kicked out of it
I stuck with Toyota's and Honda's
because those things will last 200,000
miles easy if you change the oil and
then like I bought I wanted I was I
bought at 1988 Honda Accord in 1997 so
it was nine years old and it already had
a hundred thousand [ __ ] mile or 80
something miles thousand miles on it or
something and I bought it it was
four-door nothing flashy was like a
family car
I would definitely if I was gonna buy a
used car I would go with a Toyota or a
Honda that has been Welman maintained
that's what the [ __ ] I would do and he
and then you got to pay some money
alright if he
go under six $7000 I mean jesuschrist
buying somebody else's [ __ ] problems
just go out get a loan you'll get some
credit and believe me just pay off the
[ __ ] loan it's gonna be a lot less
cheaper there was nothing even funny in
that that's just what I'll tell you all
right
at least they make the American cars
better now but I don't know I'm [ __ ]
jaded when it comes to that [ __ ] because
I came up in the 80s when they started
making American cars disposable one of
the worst [ __ ] things they could ever
do like the car was literally designed
to [ __ ] the bed at 80,000 [ __ ] miles
while the Japanese were making them to
last 200,000 so do the [ __ ] math it's
a terrible [ __ ] time
oh my god that was such a terrible time
and then they shrunk down Cadillacs to
making the size of a Chevy citation dude
I don't bring up this car all the time
the [ __ ] American cars I don't know
what happened to him they they made
during that period they like liked those
cars like I watch when I watch those uh
those auctions on TV there's no cars
from the [ __ ] 80s that are American
the only thing you'll see you'll see
like a like the Buick Grand National
there's one that was the top-of-the-line
one that that like to this day can beat
most cars you know just a [ __ ] badass
looking car and that one has retained
its value there's there's very few but
like I don't even know what a [ __ ]
Impala looked like in the 80s no one
gave a [ __ ] but impalas from the early
70s all the way back to like 1958 and 59
everybody loves him I don't know so they
used they made this Chevy citation they
forgot to put the [ __ ] radio in so
they had to turn it like like sideways
I'll try to put a picture of that up on
the website but I don't know yeah that's
my advice dude I would I would go with
the Toyota or a Honda and I would pay
like seven eight grand for the [ __ ]
thing and I would buy it off somebody
and and don't be afraid if it has like a
hundred thousand [ __ ] miles on it
because if somebody maintain it that
thing's gonna that thing can go 300
thousand miles you know that's what I
would do all right
good luck to you don't buy it off your
[ __ ] relatives cuz they they'll [ __ ]
you over as you as you've seen alright
[ __ ] that was like a public service
announcement their advice eight Bell I
love you comedy really do you [ __ ] I
look forward to it every Monday all
right it gets me Jesus Christ with it
okay I want to ask you some questions
ask it
I'm 25 years old and have been married
for two years to a great woman no kids
yet we live very close to all of her
family parents grandparents cousins all
of them oh Jesus yeah absolutely that
can be a [ __ ] nightmare
all right you better you better have the
ground rules down all right and be like
listen I know your family [ __ ] lives
right around the corner but this is my
house
alright it's my [ __ ] house they only
come around on the holidays don't you
show up like Kramer on Seinfeld
it's nothing be none of that twenty
anyways her grandmother is planning this
big three day long family reunion this
summer and as much as I love my wife I
would rather take a [ __ ] on a hookers
toilet then go to this thing yeah
absolutely dude you surrounded by him
I spend far too much time with their
family as it is and worst of all I think
it might conflict with when you come to
do a show in my hometown I told her
today that if her you reunion is the
same weekend that you come to town that
I will just have to skip the reunion
good man she let me have it for about
how important this is to her this is
what they dope this is what they do how
her family comes first and if I was a
good person I would go to the reunion
and then she started to cry
oh dude she hit you with both barrels
both barrels
dude this is a fucked-up one I'm
actually gonna whisper and my lovely
woman is [ __ ] four states away
I had this [ __ ] argument I had this
argument [ __ ] a week ago all right
oh my god you got to get to the post you
got to get to the mailbox first and look
for those [ __ ] wedding invitations
all right and you get that and you
just rip it up and fire it over the
[ __ ] fence all right I didn't do that
all right I saw it I knew it was an
invitation and she gets his [ __ ]
invitation to go to a goddamn wedding
all right in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere all right and I said I'm not
going I'm not going
and then she starts telling me how
important these people are to her and I
said give me a [ __ ] break they're
important to you I've never heard you
say their names I don't even recognize
these names how can this be important
how could me and then she didn't then
she starts faint she just did the exact
[ __ ] same thing short of the crime
you know I would think that you would
want to go with this to me this is
important and blah blah blah it's like
sweetheart I spend my life in airports
on airplanes I don't want to go to an
extra [ __ ] thing okay tell him to put
it on skype and I'll sit there and watch
it with you I don't want to [ __ ] go
to it right let me ask do we ask them to
go to any [ __ ] like I would never drag
my girl to a football game she hates it
what I said this is really important to
me and you're a good person you going
tailgating good truck with me it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
I don't want to go so anyways then she
started to cry he said I have got a lot
of a lot of this [ __ ] since I got
married yeah I could tell you that dude
cuz you're 25 you know you 25 if you're
25 and you get [ __ ] married a woman
is gonna be 10 years beyond you just
knowing how to [ __ ] roll over you in
a relationship but you not all is not
lost all is not lost let me finish this
um if anything happens in her family I
have to be there even if it's as small
as her cousin graduating from the third
grade I'm sick of it I mean I really
hate doing stuff like this she knows I
don't like it but if I was just a flat
out tell her I hate it it would break
her heart all right so you're a decent
guy okay I would hate to do that because
she's my wife and I love her all right
is he a good guy thinking about her okay
oh and I see my family and I see my
family about once the year
since they live on the other side of the
country she just doesn't understand that
I did not grow up in a family where we
spend a ton of time together so [ __ ]
[ __ ] life family reunions doesn't mean
that much to me I feel like those ladies
should understand that if I miss one
weekend with them to see my favorite
comedian who I might not get a chance to
see again in a very long time then
that's all right how do I let her know
how I feel and get her to give me some
space and not crush my balls about going
to all of her family stuff all right
dude this is what you do
you hit your heart your hearts in the
right place you don't want to hurt her
okay and I'm gonna kind of side with
your wife on this one in that not really
siding with her but you picked the wrong
one to put your foot down on all right
what you had to do is put your foot down
on you no little Mikey just made his
first [ __ ] popsicle stick house we
all have to go over and look at it
that's something that you can blow off
like a major family reunion you kind of
got to go to that you got to be by her
side
okay so that she can prove that see I
got one he loves me right so this is
what you you what you are right now
you're in a great position to barter
okay because you're gonna make the
sacrifice and not see in my show okay so
this is what you tell her just say
listen my favorite comedian is coming to
town just like you said I might not get
another chance to see him but because
this is so important to you I want to be
there for you so I will go okay and
she'll say all right thank you and then
you say however
all right this is when you barter and
just say all this and I don't know how
to say this eloquently because I just
have to get to the point all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] these kunti little
stupid-ass [ __ ] things I don't give a
[ __ ] about you I don't want to go to
them anymore okay
I work all day I come home I want to
chill out I don't know your family I
don't know I married you okay you want
to go that you know the Oscars are your
family reunion I will go to that [ __ ]
okay your dad gets
new colostomy bag I'm not showing up to
that I am NOT going to all of them I
will go to some major ones
I will go to Christmastime I'll put on
the sweater all right but this [ __ ]
24/7 all the [ __ ] time
Suzi [ __ ] is having a birthday party
I'm not going to it I'm staying home and
I'm watching the game okay because it's
making me miserable
and I want to be happy with you all
right and this is the thing she might
give you [ __ ] about that but no you got
it you got to put your foot down and let
her cry about it all right and just say
this isn't fair to me this isn't fair to
me that all of my free time involves
being with your family all right I don't
know how you say it dude you got to
figure out to say it's [ __ ] boring
good lord going over there I don't like
the smell of their house I don't like
their food I don't like the color their
plates I just want to get the [ __ ] out
of there I'm not comfortable you are go
over there they're prompt they probably
don't even like you going over there you
know they want their girl over there so
[ __ ] go over there so that that's
what I would do um you just play her
game all right my show is as important
to you as that [ __ ] thing so why
don't why don't you cry no I can't do
that but you know what I'm saying just
flip it around just be like all right
well I want you to know that I'm missing
my favorite [ __ ] comedian to go to
this thing okay and I will go to this
thing okay but from here on out I am
only going to the major ones okay
because I love you I support you but
this ticky-tack [ __ ] horseshit
that's all you I'm not I'm not doing
that okay cuz I need a life outside of
this outside of your family all right go
[ __ ] yourself love you love you buttons
I'll see you later
there you go how's that was that work
I'm overrated underrated for the week
overrated school school is nothing but a
waste of time and money I graduated
school last summer and now I go to
community college my dad harasses me
every day to get my ass up and listen to
an old ass man talk about something that
has nothing to do with my career I am a
model and an actress and I don't know
what the [ __ ] to do with 2 X plus 4
equals 8 what does that have to do with
me remembering my lines I swear I hate
that place so much all right
underrated well I don't know it was
really school isn't overrated it's uh I
think I don't you if you want to be a
model and an actress yeah you should why
the [ __ ] you taking algebra but algebra
isn't overrated you need algebra you
need geometry without geometry we
couldn't build [ __ ] so it's not
overrated I think what you should have
said was it was annoying but good luck
with your modeling and acting career I
hope I see you at the [ __ ] Oscars all
right
and don't get naked don't do that don't
[ __ ] it up keep it classy that'll make
you that'll set you apart from this
ocean of horse look just how like
mainstream dressing like a [ __ ] has
become you know and how successful you
can come become by just being a [ __ ]
skank like that raven-haired chick right
who needs to be steamed cleaned because
she's blown every six round draft pick
out there
underrated going to school with a slight
buzz I hate school so much that one day
I decided to steal some of my dad's
liquor I must admit that school was a
bit more amusing that day so I continued
to do it now I know that might sound
like I have a problem but I really don't
care whatever gets me through the day
I'm cool with it
oh dude that's a dangerous [ __ ]
that's a dangerous road to go down you
know obviously school sucks it's boring
you want to get the [ __ ] out of there
you know you want to go drink and [ __ ]
something your human being right but
when you start I don't know being able
to be hammered or being high you know
first time you smoked a joint you're
able to actually function without
freaking out you get away with it and
you think it's [ __ ] awesome it really
isn't it isn't you got too much freedom
so I would
advised not to do that but you know what
you didn't ask me for my advice so I
don't give a [ __ ]
how's that how's that what are we up to
here fifty [ __ ] one minutes nine more
goddamn minutes hey can anybody explain
to me why NBA basketball is so [ __ ]
long
dad I asked that question yet it's the
only one when you jump from college to
pro it becomes longer college football
is for 15 minute quarters college
hockey's 3:20 minute quarters and as far
as I know college baseball is nine
innings college hoop is two 20-minute
halves and then you go to the pros and
they add those eight excruciating ly
boring [ __ ] minutes why did why did
they do that I was actually watching I
watched a lot of college hoops a Kansas
game was at Kansas Missouri and I
watched Kentucky play somebody else
[ __ ] the most exciting bass like I
love college basketball 2020 you done
it's like the first half is over so
[ __ ] quick and then when you're in
the second half it becomes crunch time
so much quicker the crowds are going
crazy that's one of my goals man I want
to go to where the Jayhawks play and I
want to go to a Kentucky I went to a
Indiana Hoosiers game a long time ago
when I was on the road when Bobby Knight
was still coaching and he was screaming
at the kids and I was [ __ ] getting
angry watching him you know it's going
like it's no whack if I could play for a
guy like that screaming at me like that
you know I have to I have like a temper
as bad as his that that would be a bad
[ __ ] mix but yeah if anybody can
answer me that question is it just
strictly for money III don't understand
um the [ __ ] was oh I got it I gotta do
some of the rest of the advertising to
hear people it's trying to make this
amusing here try to make a little funny
here gamefly.com this is nothing that
you guys been really responded to you
know I'm really trying to get stuff that
you guys are interested in so you won't
be bored during these ads and then also
you know all these things are gonna come
with a discount so I'm trying to hook
you up so if you have any suggestions of
[ __ ] that you like you know that you
want a discount on maybe I'd get them to
advertise in my podcast here gamefly.com
everybody that's where I it's the video
rental system that delivers
video games to your door and now PC
games right to your PC see that how how
much easier can it get people just sit
there on the couch like Brad Pitt and
true romance and they're just gonna
bring it right to you
Gamefly has over eight thousand titles
to choose from eight thousand different
games ok tell me this isn't for a gamer
you can't tell me that this isn't a
dream come true you can't tell me that
you didn't sit on the couch like dude
would it be awesome if we could just sit
here and have every game ever delivered
to us snap our fingers and it's on a
computer where you can do that
gamefly.com Monday morning podcast
listeners get a free 15 day trial dude
even if you're not gonna sign up with
this stuff you got to go for the 15 day
trial free 15 days 8000 games
Colin work telling me got the whooping
cough you got yellow fever the bubonic
plague whatever you got to say and play
games for 15 straight days you go to
games W decide do it for the 15 free day
free trial go to WWE and fly calm / / bu
are are all lowercase alright going
there you sign up eight thousand video
games 15 day free trial god bless you
America and here you go my favorite of
all favorites Kate fender everybody
skate fenders are this is this is the
stuff I've been using playing hockey
although I hadn't played hockey the last
couple weeks because of Murphy's Law
because I know I have to I got a tape my
special so I've never hurt myself
knock on wood you know but God knows if
I'm gonna it's gonna be the week of my
special and I've never seen a comedian
with the torn ACL ever give a good
performance during a comedy prefer uh
special other than Joe DeRosa a lot of
people don't know on joe de Rosa's last
half-hour special I actually I think
it's his only one you know he's like
Shah day he does like one every eight
years you know he goes into hiding you
know like like a true artist that he is
you know you know he makes his
easels that's how much of an artist the
teen idol sensation Joe DeRosa is was I
talking about what it was oh yeah he
blew out his ACL you know he blew out
his ACL he was he was jerking off right
and he was about ready to come and you
know his [ __ ] legs got so tight and
he doesn't work out just it just snapped
and evidently it enhanced his orgasm but
he had to do a special the next day and
you know you never would have known it
like [ __ ] Willis Reed man he just limp
right through it
and I'm - [ __ ] am I talking about skate
fender calm everybody skate finish I
mean hockey players are out there right
you play hockey like me you skate around
frontwards backwards give me the puck
hate this guy why doesn't he pass he's
so selfish alright is there anything
worse than taking a puck to the foot you
know you got padding everywhere up some
reason you don't have it there I've
always wondered that why the hell don't
they do some to protect your foot
evidently studies have shown that taking
a hundred-mile-an-hour slap shot to the
foot is like being shot by 22 caliber if
you haven't taken one half that speed
okay I don't care how much of a man you
are you collapse to the ground like you
have a swatch hockey watch NHL hockey
when someone takes a slap shut up to
foot it looks like they get shot they
just collapsed to the ground because
it's like you got shot in the foot with
the 22 caliber well the wonderful people
over at skate fender they created these
things the skate fenders and I tried him
out last week as I said it fits right
over your foot molds right to your foot
you know three different sizes you put
it on there lighter than socks you can't
even tell you're wearing them and then
one day you're out there and somebody
takes a slap shot you take it off your
foot dude and it's like Christmas you
can't feel it the I mean you know you
got hit but you can't it's like getting
hit with the shin guard it doesn't even
hurt okay so there you go and not to
mention 19 of the 30 teams in the NHL
are already wearing them okay and who's
kidding who most of us the NHL dream is
over you got a real day job do you want
to walk in there with one swollen foot
and give that presentation you don't
alright be the first one to get him
alright this is what you do it's
affordable for all players at all levels
and if you use the Bilborough promo code
you will get five dollars off
what is the promo code when the hell is
it it's effective in reducing painful
debilitating impact injuries do I have
the thing used by professional teams
including the Detroit Red Wings where
the hell is my promo code I don't know I
don't know what the hell it is but if
you use it you get $5 off who cares just
go there protect your damn feet I'm
using them they're tremendous and if you
notice somebody special I will not be
limping because I wear skate fenders all
right and that's it that's the podcast
for this week everybody um I got a great
feeling about this special everybody I
really do man I'm going hard I'm not
holding back and I think I got it man I
got that perfect balance of going off on
[ __ ] that nobody gives a [ __ ] about you
know neutral whatever I got some bunch
of self-deprecating [ __ ] I got some
silly [ __ ] I got personal [ __ ] and then
I got a nice [ __ ] rent you know it's
like a great meal
you got your veggies you got your
[ __ ] toothpaste and you got your
[ __ ] [ __ ] sitting right there to
cross the table she ain't gonna pay is
she huh stop acting like you're going
for your wallet like you're gonna pay
yeah that's something I never pulled you
know back kind of when I used to go on
dates you know when I slicked back when
I had a full head of red hair and I'd
slick it back like Clark Kent you know I
did that too you know like Superman you
know when I did stand-up I parted it on
the left side and when I went on a date
I was on the right side you know wasn't
even funny I know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about what am I talking about
here I got it I got a special coming out
everybody I'm taping it next week and
I'm [ __ ] ready to go all right I got
a new button-down shirt I got a pair of
jeans and some new shoes and I'm [ __ ]
doing this thing all right gonna [ __ ]
do this thing and then I am drinking on
the plane and we're landing in st. Louis
and I'm gonna be taking off in cuffs
that's my game plan for next week
all right so you guys go [ __ ] yourselves
well before I say that thank you for for
doing all this stuff I really appreciate
the everybody going to amazon.com it's
such a great thing to be able to you
know make a little money on this podcast
and then actually do a good thing with
some of the money you don't I mean not
gonna lie to you I'm keeping most of the
money all right and I'm saving up for
one of those new rolling electronic drum
kits that's my next thing that I'm gonna
buy although I have to get that by Nia
where are we gonna put it it's too big I
know but it's fun oh you know what I
actually bought a new drum pedal I'm
gonna let you guys know about this thing
because I've been trying to do that Jojo
Mayer thing I'm getting back into that
trying to get my face done speed up I
just wanna be able to do three in a row
[ __ ] solid and really quick you know
what I mean I just wanna be that guy we
let people listen to you play like you
got a double pedal no I dumped its one
foot uh-huh
that's one foot then I can use do that
other thing you see that [ __ ] what
people just do that little rocking back
and forth and they get that hi-hat
splash and sound all right that was for
the three drummers who listen to this
[ __ ] thing all right that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
don't take any [ __ ] I'll see you next
week and now let you know how the
special goes and I'm gonna be on
vacation for four days four days I am
off and then I am working on some other
project that has nothing to do with
comedy if you live in Los Angeles and
you'd like to watch me bomb trying out
my new stuff all during March you'll see
me I'll be dipping in and out of the
Comedy Store on Sunset um that is it
here the excitement I'm ready I'm in the
[ __ ] I'm in this I'm into whatever
whatever the [ __ ] you say I'm ready to
do this and I'm babbling cuz I'm not
excited all right I'll talk to you next
week I'll let you know how it goes
I already said that for the love of God
shut up
you